pop
[Musique]
900 médecins se sont réunis à paris sous
la présidence du professeur pasteur
valérie raddho parmi eux le professeur
portier qui voici cinquante ans
découvrit les phénomènes fondamentaux
d'une affection aujourd'hui à la mode
sous le nom d'allergies on la
connaissait depuis longtemps sous
d'autres noms l'asthme allergique
l'eczéma allergies le rhume des foins
allergies elle peut y avoir des causes
professionnelles
mais on peut aussi être allergique aux
poussières aux poils de chat
[Musique]
en plumes aux pollens ou simplement à la
lessive et la vie moderne vote à un
français sur deux des manifestations
allergiques
prenons le cas d'une allergie aux
poussières une poussière rencontrons une
cellule dans l'organisme créé un
anticorps qui va sensibiliser une autre
cellule qu'on aspire une nouvelle
poussière elle va libérer de la cellule
sensibiliser un poison violent
l'histamine agents de toutes les
allergies à l'hôpital broussais les
laboratoires sont à l'avant garde du
combat on y à vérifier le processus de
l'allergie en créant artificiellement
l'affection sur des cobayes
comme pour cette crise d'asthme
[Musique]
mieux sur un poumon isolé mise en état
de survie dont la respiration assuré par
une pompe est normal on constate que
l'introduction de pollen bloque la
respiration et bien que la pompe
continue de fonctionner c'est la crise
d'asthme
[Musique]
et
l'injection d'un contrepoison rétablira
le rythme normal
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
on obtient le même résultat en traitant
un cobaye le contrepoison ou antigène
une fois fixé sur les cellules les
protègent de l'histamine
[Musique]
et on ne retrouve les symptômes de la
crise que celle aux cobayes non traitées
chez l'homme le premier acte des soins
consiste à déterminer les agents
chimiques responsables
on procède par tests successifs ici par
scarifications jusqu'au moment où on
découvre une réaction positive
[Musique]
à la fondation rothschild on procède à
de véritables enquêtes policières
[Musique]
ici le professeur sidi développe les
pestes par contact épicutanée
[Musique]
au terme de ces enquêtes les malades
peuvent maintenant recevoir des piqûres
de désensibilisation qui diminue
progressivement les manifestations de
l'allergie chaque cas doit être traité
spécifiquement d'où ces vaccins et
inattendue
[Musique]
l'allergie se rappelle bientôt
définitivement vaincu les travaux du
docteur halpern et de son équipe de
brousse est le laisse respirer
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]